hi i'm matt lundgren i'm the co-director
of the stanford center for artificial
intelligence and medicine imaging and an
associate professor in the department of
radiology at stanford i'm here to talk
today about clinical machine learning
[Music]
and these are my disclosures
so as you may be aware we're sort of
entering a period where we expect to
have a significant physician shortfall
worldwide their estimates widely vary as
you can imagine but nonetheless we're
seeing already the effects of a lack of
physician and medical expertise around
the world and how it's impacting care
and leading to incredibly large
disparities around the world
at the same time we live in a
information overload society
we have noticed that despite the fact
that our training in medicine has
essentially stayed the same since it was
formalized in the 50s at the time
medical information doubled about every
50 years so you could expect that if
you're trained around that time if you
just kept up
generally speaking with the medical
literature you would be able to be up to
date throughout most of your career
that's obviously changed medical
information doubles about every 73 days
which makes it almost impossible for us
in the medical profession no matter how
sub-specialized we are to maintain a
level of understanding of the most
innovative and and latest evidence and
as we move towards medical imaging we
recognize that there's an enormous
amount of investment spurred in part by
those trends i've just talked about
massive amounts of information and of
course data but also a
huge gap
in the uh this dissemination of medical
expertise and so we see a lot of
information that is being invested uh in
into this space and we're sort of
getting to a place where now we
understand that the field has become
quite crowded with folks like these
these are just a sampling some of these
companies are
focused specifically on medical imaging
some are focused on ai and healthcare
more broadly but we recognize that
there's a large amount of interest and
investment from the commercial space
again spurred by a lot of these trends
and of course the advent of deep
learning
when we kind of look across the
landscape of the different groups that
are focused on uh clinical machine
learning we recognize that
there are pros and cons i guess from
each perspective right and we can see
that for example ai startups tend to
have technical knowledge they certainly
have access to compute interdisciplinary
teams are a tougher cell and certainly
the access to data and particularly for
the imaging use case labeled medical
imaging data is is a huge bottleneck and
a huge problem
whereas when we compare sort of across
again
looking at academic medical centers for
example
we are in we believe the best position
to continue to lead in this space
despite the fact that investments may be
occurring elsewhere
we have the knowledge off from the
compute we have interdisciplinary teams
we have lots of lots of data that we can
label and work with in-house
we have infrastructure for deployment
and evaluation
and of course we can disseminate through
our various channels and so we are in a
very unique position right now with
respect to the rest of the field and the
community to lead in this space
and that's something that did not escape
our notice when we set out to begin
creating the center at stanford for
artificial intelligence and medicine
imaging what began as essentially five
faculty and and a few research labs back
in 2017 has now
blossomed into over 130 faculty across
nine departments and three schools uh we
have key collaborations with computer
science luminaries like fei-fei li chris
manning and andreang
and we have projects that have been
sectioned off into every aspect of
medicine that you can imagine which are
co-led
by physician pis
and computer science collaborators so
it's really a wonderful ecosystem that's
continued to grow
and when we sort of put together a
mission statement as to what we seek to
do in this space
we had a lot in common with maybe other
centers and other academic groups that
you may have been familiar with but one
thing that we decided to to do early on
is differentiate ourselves by
essentially trying to create
resources innovations
and infrastructure
that could be used by not just the
stanford community but by anyone and we
have a very very strong open source
mission that i'll talk about more as we
go
we try to focus on uh again as i
mentioned interdisciplinary
collaborations to drive the field
our engagement and education
components are really against strengths
for us
we have a strong data science research
and clinical infrastructure which have
really played a role into sort of
allowing
faculty that made it may have not had a
computer science background uh in the
past or even a computer science
researcher who wanted to work with
medical data
we wanted to create an infrastructure
that would allow both of those groups to
to work together and then finally
catalyzing funding so that's either with
partnerships with industries small
startups large companies etc but just in
general being able to create a community
where
we can provide the seed funding for our
faculty to be successful
as we look at the things that are
essential for clinical ai we understand
you know we need of course data access
uh and and a community of data
scientists right to some extent these
are non-negotiable
but
oftentimes what is neglected is the idea
that we need to have additional
functionality in order for some of these
clinical machine learning applications
to actually make an impact one of them
is an understanding around cross
modality and we'll talk a little bit
more about why this is so important
but we need to not only have access to
structured and unstructured ehr data we
also need to have access to wearable
data we need to have access to genomic
data and in particular pixel data and we
need to figure out a way to
organize this data across timelines so
that we can understand the course of
healthcare
and be able to again drive what we're
trying to accomplish in terms of
deployment
and of course delivery so this is still
a nascent area in general for most of us
in healthcare but we have to be able to
bring these discoveries into the
clinical care pathways
and in a process that aligns across the
enterprise it can't just be a one-off
effort it needs to be a systematic
deployment
and that's again what we're going to
talk about near the end
[Music]
we've worked incredibly hard to create a
curriculum
uh recognizing that there are an
unlimited number of open
source sort of uh educational profiles
and platforms around
uh helping someone with a technical
background understand the uh machine
learning and healthcare applications but
there isn't much out there for those
without a technical background so all
those clinicians all the trainees all
the those in healthcare administration
and pharma other verticals that aren't
technically uh sort of coming from a
technical background we needed to have a
curriculum
that allowed them to understand the
tools and the principles behind these
technologies in order to sort of have a
meaningful interaction in a
multidisciplinary team so we started
teaching this course that's dr srina
young and myself
as a sort of collaborative clinical and
computer science background perspective
we then launched it on corsair and it's
one of the most popular courses on the
platform and again what makes it unique
is that you don't have to come in with a
computer science or coding background in
order to walk away with a with a very
strong understanding in the foundation
uh in in machine learning for for
healthcare
we have begun to sort of see the
landscape shifting from what we thought
would be a
uh primarily focused uh a group uh
meaning that we'd have small labs that
are you know incredibly ingrained in
sort of the uh you know machine learning
uh space but but instead now we're
starting to see that this is going
across the enterprise and interest comes
from almost every aspect every corner of
healthcare
in an imaging context you'd expect
radiologists pathologists and
cardiologists and others who heavily use
imaging to be leading a lot of the
drivers of change and that that is true
um but what we're starting to recognize
again is that there's there's additional
influence that's coming from both the
payers
the patients themselves
but in in particular what we're finding
the most interest
in terms of the use of clinical machine
learning in medical imaging applications
actually are clinicians that use imaging
as part of their workflow but not
necessarily primarily in their
day-to-day in other words
a radiologist might use imaging all day
every day right as you can imagine
and they might choose an ai solution to
help them be more efficient but we're
actually seeing as clinicians who use
imaging as part of taking care of their
patients are incredibly motivated to
leverage these tools and technologies at
the point of care
to take care of their patients and
potentially
feeling glean insights that would
normally be the sort of the purview of
of the
imaging specialists like radiologists
and that's a trend again that that's
come up again and again and again we're
in a room full of clinicians we're
talking about some of the things that
we're innovating on in the medical
imaging space and we consistently get
interest from those in the front line in
terms of clinicians saying how can i use
this at the point of care is this only
meant for radiologists or only meant for
pathologists and that that's been a very
interesting dynamic that we're starting
to explore more
one of the applications that we've seen
really have a lot of traction
is the idea around point of care
clinical imaging ai so in other words if
you have a clinical decision support
system
that requires a radiologist in the
workflow in other words
you're doing a chest x-ray for
deciding about pneumonia
you need to have a radiologist interpret
that that report needs to be dictated
that needs to be read and then input
into some kind of decision support tool
in order to have a physician
make a decision about treating that
patient and we've recognized that
there's an opportunity to insert ai and
other app deep learning applications
regarding the pixel data and later also
i'll talk about the multimodal data
in order to accelerate the timeline
to deliver these clinical decision
support tools that incorporate both ehr
data and the pixel data directly to the
physician at the front at the front
lines at the point of care and this is
affording some efficiencies that we've
never even seen before we've never
considered before we've certainly never
had the access to and you can imagine
that while this could make a
relatively mundane
academic medical center more efficient
or quicker this would have profound
impact on the parts of this country and
the parts of the world that don't have
access to radiologic expertise
one of the things that this is required
is a deep understanding of how we can
leverage multiple types of data in order
to derive solutions that consider all of
the possible context
so in other words we have different
types of data so in in the sort of green
and
in blue you see that there's two
different modalities and they can be
fused together in different network
architectures in order to derive
decision making uh towards a particular
input or output so for for example if i
have a chest x-ray
and i have clinical data that would
suggest this person's maybe more at risk
for lung cancer or tuberculosis or you
know acute pneumonia those kinds of data
that come from the ehr system would
actually inform that model to have a
higher performance right and it's
actually the science of how you join
these data together
to arrive at those conclusions that
really is a very interesting and new
space that we're starting to explore
more heavily this is a review article
open access you're welcome to check out
where we do a systematic review of the
literature and break down all the
different possible approaches to fuse
electronic health record data and
imaging data together to derive
conclusions around certain use cases
we we did this with a use case around
pulmonary embolism which is an
incredibly acute and important use case
often driver of a lot of medical imaging
utilization questions and certainly the
the government and cms and other payers
have a strong incentive to reduce the
the amount of this
type of work being done that's not
necessary we found that if we use just
emr or just the pixel data our our
performance is modest to good but when
we fuse them together with different
architectures we found incredibly
improved performance as you'd expect
and just here's a couple examples of a
vision model
that was able to improve its diagnosis
for permanent embolism which is in the
green boxes because it was understanding
the clinical context and the pre-test
probability was changing because of its
understanding of that and that was
really a powerful discovery that i think
will drive a lot of new applications and
more useful applications
particularly in the imaging space
that's worked by by mars wine
[Music]
but what we've seen lately as you can
imagine is an incredible transformation
towards an acceptance for both data
sharing and acceptance towards remote
and potentially leveraging point-of-care
solutions that we hadn't seen before and
that's essentially been driven by this
pandemic
we have seen uh
unusual use cases for ehr for example
the epic group has a cognitive neural
layer who has been actually leveraging
various clinical machine intelligence
solutions into its cloud architecture to
to pull in data from the hr and in this
case pull in pixel data similar to what
i've suggested just a minute ago and
derive
a score directly to the clinician in
this case for the likelihood that
someone has coven 19. so these kinds of
things are starting to push through
the traditional roadblocks and and
patterns of behavior because of the
pandemics
sort of
need and urgency
we're also seeing a lot of investment in
interest from other companies looking to
leverage point of care or pushing care
out towards again maybe a walmart clinic
or maybe even at the home with the use
of a smartphone and we're seeing that
these applications may have other
potential use cases again this is all
about at the point of care this is a
trend that we noticed in our own center
we're seeing more and more of and we're
seeing it now more than ever being
driven again by some of the pandemic use
cases
but no matter what you have in terms of
your technology and your performance and
your use case you need to have a way to
implement it
and this is that last mile problem that
is so incredibly difficult
and one of the reasons why having access
to again in our case in our large
academic medical center we can actually
have these cycles of learning through
our own system
and allow us to learn what are the best
practices
for
taking in real-time data
running inference on that whether it's
on-prem or on the cloud and what types
of infrastructure make the most sense
determining which algorithms to even run
and then understanding from a broader
perspective how we deal with quality
control and management over time as we
get begin to gather more and more of
these ai solutions in practice
we have taken a very uh standard
approach to our integration which is
sort of to understand the metrics in the
use case and actually heavily look at
the solution and what the impact of a
false positive for example or false
negative might be for these different
use cases
we have done shadow and canary
deployments which many of you would be
familiar with before we actually go live
um but then we have a lot of work that
we've been exploring around explainable
modeling and thresholding and i'm going
to talk a little bit more about why this
is so important
so what we typically do is we deploy a
model after testing it extensively even
on real-time data we try to get a sense
of what
the performance of these models might be
but once we've deployed them we actually
haven't really figured out a system
to monitor them over time because unlike
in other verticals and healthcare it's
very unlikely that you'll get the ground
truth answer in real time
so you either need to require data
gathering efforts to have experts
review cases and compare model you
either need or you potentially would
need to have the user
give you feedback in real time which
none of which sounds very good to most
uh most highly uh
sort of overstretched academic
healthcare system so we need to have
another way to monitor performance of
these models over time
and what we essentially have discovered
is that while we're very good at dealing
with software um in our it departments
because again in a large healthcare
system this is typical
we actually don't really have the
mechanisms to deal with what needs to be
monitored when it comes to ai solutions
and these include data drift concept
drift
schema changes data outages model biases
underperforming segments we don't have
visibility on these things and this is
actually a critical thing that we need
to figure out in the next few weeks
as we begin to roll out more and more
solutions here at stanford and we have a
solution now that we're working towards
so again we need to have ongoing
evaluation that's adaptive
that can sort of improve performance and
have demonstratable evidence that it
will improve performance we need to be
able to correct when we have errors in
real time before the model at scale
causes problems with our deployments
and then we need to be able to adjust
and change the model in real time and as
many of you know some of the
commercially available solutions
due to some of the fda regulations don't
allow us to unlock and retrain models
but in-house we can do that with our own
models and that gives us an advantage to
learn what exactly will be necessary and
what will be the best practices for
deploying and monitoring these systems
over time
and i want to just say a minute uh
take a minute to mention ethics and
fairness because what we've begun to
realize more and more
is that with some of these models
we are consistently
reinventing or i guess
sort of reinforcing some of the biases
that exist in health care some of them
are unseen and unknown and if we don't
have a robust methodology
to look at important subgroups both in
terms of demographics but also important
subtypes of disease
then we can be uh sort of deploying
models as we typically have seen
which could lead to negative outcomes
for certain groups or certain diagnoses
and that's a huge uh that's a huge
problem for us it's a huge threat to our
field in general and it is incredibly
important that we continue to push hard
on methodologies to understand ethics
and fairness both in our models before
deployment and in real time as they're
being deployed
and so what we've what we've looked to
build is basically a computational model
monitoring system so it doesn't matter
whether you have an ehr model one of
these fusion models i've mentioned a
pixel only model whatever
if you don't have an ml op system that's
balanced and sort of
i guess optimized for health care use
cases
it's unlikely that these models will see
success in the long run
we need to know our performance we need
to be able to debug them we have to know
how to evaluate these things without
requiring laborious ground truth and
data collection for every single
possible use case and then finally for
the fda
we expect the reporting
standards to change
and we also expect that these kinds of
monitoring systems to understand when
the model is drifting away from baseline
performance we need to understand when
this is happening
so this is actually the goal that we
should be shooting for as you see that
large amount of models that are being
created both in the commercial space and
on academic centers heading towards
deployment
these systems must be in place
so just to wrap up
we've
worked very hard to create an
environment and infrastructure to allow
some of these innovations for machine
learning and health care to to really
move forward but part of that mission
has also been been able to make this
available for practically anyone in the
world releasing data releasing models
releasing our most recent learnings and
work and trying to drive the field
forward that so everyone can benefit
from the work that we're all doing
together
thank you very much this is how you can
engage us in our center and i'm
happy to take questions offline